Vince cables very unhappy about this he
wants a protection against foreign
takeovers well I mean this is a
transformational deal for Aviva if you
put a diva's products which are
basically about engineering design and
and the early part of the cycle with the
Snyder products you're creating a really
unique model this company will still be
listed in the UK it'll still have its
headquarters in the UK and if you're
operating in the tech sector you're a
global business and I see this is a
great opportunity to make the ever
bigger company the company will be for
the shareholders two and a half times
the size of the company it is today and
I think it's a great opportunity not
just smoothie but but for the UK a lot
of these Shinoda assets were actually
originally based in Kearney weren't they
yes that's right and so in a way the
products are coming back into the UK and
really if you look at it overall the
suite is something really unique on a
global basis I think it should be looked
at that way the Financial Times in its
coverage of this today broken by Sky
News I should add they're saying that
this is the end of an era for silicon
fen well I mean our office in Aviva is
not going to change in Cambridge
effective might get bigger who knows but
I think that's an oversimplification to
me Cambridge will remain a very
important area and we certainly will
continue to do development work there
could you envisage a situation where
Aviva was taking over a comparable
French business well who knows in the
future I mean this is a company with
Snyder and the board of Aviva want to
grow so we'll be looking at
opportunities around the world not just
in France but other parts of the world
well unless we forget you're also
chairman of Balfour Beatty one of the
UK's big infrastructure companies you're
working on hs2 and Hinkley Point C how
do you regard the infrastructure set to
right now as it's still pretty buoyant
yes I think obviously we were delighted
to win those two large contracts on hs2
and now to win the contract on the at
Hinkley you know there's tremendous
opportunities I mean there's going to be
more investment infrastructure in the UK
and I think Balfour Beatty is very well
set now going forward to do that
obviously he thread runway is that
project we'd like to see go ahead
opportunities with Crossrail to but you
know this stage we're very delighted
what we've got with hs2 and Hinkley and
that's
keep us busy for a while I'm famously
balfour beatty walks away from merger
proposals from Karelian who have since
fallen flat on their face I mean are
there many more potential casualties in
the sector I think you've got above
themselves well you know it's hard for
me to really comment but I'd hope that
most of its out of the way now I mean
personally you know we have Karelian can
work through their problems we had
similar problems a few years back
but I think the build Alaska program
which Leo Quinn Borden has now put let
us back on a much better cost basis and
cash wise and I think we're now in good
shape to grow going forward and I think
that will happen with other companies
over a period of time maybe we were
ahead of our time and only up to some of
those problems very very briefly the
Australian press is linked you with a
takeover for a contra City Football Club
any truth in that no look there was a
group of Australians who were looking at
Charlton Football Club and Coventry came
up to my name's been used in a few of
these things I've been an Australian in
London for many years now and every time
there's something linking into something
in Australia my name seems to pop up
that I think Bell forbidding the Beavers
gonna keep you pretty busy alright for
the Viking good to see ya thanks did you
want anything you